she has learned how to roll with the
punches or in this specific case a shoe
because she had one thrown at her
yesterday while making a speech at a
metal recycling conference does she miss
the former Secretary of State the former
first lady a woman was taken into
custody after admitting that she was the
picture the shooting process Clinton
joked about the incident but uh Peter
does this happen pretty often I mean she
she's she's still got a lot of fans she
does she also has a pretty substantial
secure all things happen when Tom comes
to DC strange things happen scarlet that
shoe of zipper fly that could have hurt
her right there it's serious stuff the
fact that she can make a few jokes
afterwards tells me she is ready to be
running for president she is sorry that
he is relaxed and ready it could have
hurt her yeah what is it one more was
arrested I mean where is approach this
come from do we identify the woman that
I think I believe it was a woman and
through it do we understand her politics
I'm the little reporting I've seen on it
says we don't know exactly what her
motivation was why she did it
and of course brings us back Baghdad and
changed my socks in three days a large
shoe that just came by my head Garlits
you know often oh there it goes
delayed reaction here's another shoe
that's been coming for you Tom